- [Voiceover] Blast off.
- [Voiceover] Astronauts have to deal
with a lot of dangers in space,
deadly debris, harmful cosmic rays,
and sometimes a corned beef sandwich.
(boom)
- [Voiceover] Houston,
we've had a problem.
- [Voiceover] In the 1960s at the height
of the space race, space
food was either compressed
into utilitarian packages
or pureed into a tube.
NASA did this in part
to reduce the dangers
free-floating crumbs could pose,
like wreaking havoc on the
space capsule's instruments.
During the Gemini 3 mission,
astronaut John Young
didn't quite get the memo when he snuck
a contraband corned beef
sandwich into space.
Sure, the sandwich could've caused
a life-threatening accident,
(suspenseful music)
but hey, wouldn't you wanna know
how a sandwich tasted in space?
Here's how the event
played out between Young
and his co-pilot Gus Grissom.
- [Voiceover] Elapsed time of 02 28 25,
roll left, 5-5.
What is it?
- [Voiceover] Corned beef sandwich.
- [Voiceover] Where did it come from?
- [Voiceover] I brought it with me.
Let's see how it tastes.
(biting)
It smells, doesn't it?
(groan)
- [Voiceover] Yep.
It's breaking up.
- [Voiceover] Is it?
- [Voiceover] I'm gonna
stick it in my pocket.
- [Voiceover] It was a thought anyway.
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- [Voiceover] Not a very good one.
- [Voiceover] And NASA and Congress didn't
think so either.
Young was reprimanded for his actions
but luckily for him, the incident
didn't derail his career.
He later was part of the Apollo 16 mission
and walked on the moon,
but that time he made sure
to leave his packed lunch at home.
- [Voiceover] Tranquility Base
here, the Eagle has landed.